says he belongs to a life science
background uh can you let me know what
is your educational degree as well
are you from a microbiology or a biology
background let me know in the chat
and um it would be great if the rest of
you could introduce yourself in the chat
box
all right so vikar says he has done his
Master's in medical laboratory science
so I'm curious to know um what made you
interested in the field of bioinismatics
we have a specific research interest in
mind
so for those participants who have just
joined uh we are just introducing
yourself in the chat box
um you can let me know are you from a
biology background or from a computer
science background in your in the chat
box I'm monitoring that
we will be starting with the webinar in
just few more minutes
all right we have
test this because I hope I'm pronouncing
your name correct otherwise you can let
me know so Festus is from a computer
science background
um that's pretty cool uh can you let me
know what made you interested in the
field of bioinformatics
do you have a specific research interest
in mind
foreign
tics and and it's at Masters level but
still learning and wish to do PhD in
clients
that's pretty interesting do you have a
specific research interest within
bioinformatics
we do have a couple of students from
computer science background who have
been doing projects on machine learning
do you have any such interest let me
know in the chat
all right so meanwhile the participants
can introduce yourself in the chat box
I'm going to start with today's webinar
so hello everyone a very warm greeting
to one and all my name is Krishna Kumar
and I would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on introduction to
bioinformatics multionics so this online
program is designed for everyone
including students who don't have a
background in bioinformatics and
biologists to learn about NGS data
analysis processing sections such as
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics and as a result the
participants will become proficient in
analysis and interpretation of various
types of omics data using bi-informatics
including commonly used statistical and
machine learning techniques in today's
webinar we will first learn to sign up
on The omits Logical on total and learn
how to navigate the various courses and
example projects that you will be
completing as a part of the program
followed by this we will have a Hands-On
session by the program Mentor where you
will learn to run bi-inchmatic pipelines
for various sections such as genomics
transatomics and metagenomics finally
they will also cover details about the
program registration process and program
cost
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based by informatics
company who's working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that have been completed by
over 24 000 participants from 187
countries in over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and Regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
Logistics and adapting them to the needs
of students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to the
omen strategic resources but how does it
help Advance bioinformatics teaching
omic's logic is important for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the students a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omix logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like art and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the oming Strategic courses which
includes courses on bioinformatics
Precision medicine multi elements that
consist of genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics data
science that makes use of bioinformatics
for R and python as well as
cheminformatics and example projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work
now as a part of the program students
will also be given access to the T by
info platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multiomics platform
more on this will be covered during this
webinar
so now to view the various courses
example projects student projects you
need to first sign up on the omics logic
learn portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles and a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests
and the mentors under the activity tab
the mentors can do your learning
progress
and under the courses tab you will be
able to view the various courses that
you are currently completing finally
after the completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates so this was all about uh
the almost logical on Portal so now let
us Begin by signing up on the portal for
that I'm sharing the link to the portal
in the chat box
so please click on that link and I'll
show you how you can sign up on the
portal
so for those participants who are
creating an account for the first time
you can simply click on the create an
account option that you see here and
here you can enter your name your email
ID and password this is one way to sign
up on the portal or you can also sign up
using any of your social media handles
this could be your Google Facebook Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
so you can simply click on that and you
will be able to sign
so I'll pause for a couple of seconds
and I'll be monitoring the chat once the
participants have signed up on the
portal please put a yes in the chat box
so that I can show you the various
courses and example projects that are
there on the portal
and along the way if you're having any
queries or any technical issues that
you're facing you can put that in the
chat as well and we'll be happy to look
into it
I'm monitoring the chat please click on
the link and sign up as I explained
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I know I can proceed for those
participants who already have an account
on the portal you can simply click on
login now option that you see here and
simply click on sign in
all right so vikar says he has signed up
[Music]
all right so I'm going to proceed along
but a long way if you're having any
queries let me know
um so I since I already have an account
on the portal I'm just going to click on
sign in
so once you sign in you will be able to
see the various courses and example
projects that are there so when you
scroll below that you can see a search
bar that asks for looking for a specific
course so here you can enter your topic
of Interest so since most of you are
beginners in bioinformatics you can
simply by informatics
and I have to show you the very
introductory courses that makes use of
the bioinformatics concept so let's say
you have a very specific research
interest such as machine learning so you
can simply enter the keyword you see
learning
and that will show you the various
courses and example projects that are
there on the
so this is how you can navigate the
various courses that are there on the
portal but for now uh let's go on to the
part where I was discussing about
updating your account for that you can
simply click on the welcome back with
your email ID card that you see here so
once you click on this uh this will be
displayed in front of you so here you
will be able to see an icon that says
profile just simply click on that and
here you will be able to edit your
profile so as I explained my
presentation you can enter your name
make sure that it has to be in proper
capitalization and you can also enter
your a brief bio about yourself so that
will be your educational background and
research interests so in my case it's
autoimmune diseases and Neuroscience so
I've entered that and also please make
sure that you update a profile image for
yourself and also put a link for your
social media hands so in my case I've
linked my LinkedIn account and my
quality so that was about updating your
profile so this is the activity tab
where the program mentor and the
community manager will be tracking your
learning progress
and once you start picking up any of the
courses the code it will be displayed
under the courses tab as you can see I'm
currently completing transcriptomics
analysis in Python so that is displayed
here and once you complete a project and
upload it on our portal it will be
displayed under the project step so once
you enroll for the program such as the
multiomics program that will be
displayed under the programs
and finally after the completion of your
coursework and the associated
quizzes and assignments the certificates
will appear under the certificates
so this was all about navigating through
the quarter and you can also take a look
at some of the student projects that are
there under the projects tab you can
take a look at a wide variety of the
projects that students have completed on
topics ranging from infectious diseases
oncology Neuroscience machine learning
and so on so with that if the
participants have any queries please let
me know in the chat and I'll be happy to
help has everyone signed up
because today is going to be a Hands-On
session it is important that you sign up
uh so that you can make use of the
resources that are there
all right so if the participants have no
further queries you get we can start
with the
um next session that is the Hands-On
session by the program Mentor so for
that I would like to invite Dr
raghavendra Lakshmi Narayan to start the
today's session over to you
thank you very much recovery and thank
you for everybody to um chime in about
your introduction and I've been
following everything very nice we have a
a good set of participation who are
interested and also who have some
introduction to bioinformatics also I
see that Cynthia has raised her hand and
uh
uh if you have any query please
yeah let me know if not then we can move
ahead
okay
I think we have a request for sharing uh
request
yes the website link for signing up
yes I'll reshare the link okay thank you
very much and please signing up so
uh usually what happens is after you
sign up we will have to distribute your
credentials for the server which I am
going to demonstrate to you today so we
initially we had planned for some uh
participation from you also to work with
us while I'm demonstrating you but due
to some technical reasons that's not
going to happen so what you can do
instead is you can get the recording of
today's video and then you can use your
credentials and then work with me when
in the server and the server's
capability which we are going to discuss
today in your own Leisure right okay
this will also work if you already have
your credentials to the t-bio info
server which we are going to discuss in
detail today so um if you are repeating
the participant and if you have already
signed up earlier and you have
credentials to log into the tbio info
server that we are going to talk about
please let me know uh in the chat box
and and yeah and you can sign in to your
TV info server account and then you can
follow along with me okay let me find
ways to share my screen and set it up
let's have everything so that it doesn't
hiccup in between
okay uh please confirm that you can see
my screen I'm going to be monitoring the
chat while we are in the
while we are discussing so if you have
any questions please put it up in the
chat
yes
okay excellent so let's go over the
program page to understand what do we
have here and how do we navigate between
different resources and uh and what are
the general syllabus and course
structure program structure of uh this
specific program so you can find the
schedule and thing you would have
already navigated towards the schedule
earlier so I'm not going to go over the
schedule and those details so we always
start with an introduction session right
where we are going to introduce
bioinformatics to those who are new to
bioinformatics and this is not only
specific to people who are new to
bioinformatics but this is this is a
concise introduction a concise overall
view of bioinformatics and its
application in various different areas
ranging from agriculture to treatment
response and patient certification and
etc etc right in and pandemic response
etcetera everything that you can think
about using a high throughput sequencing
or next Generation sequencing technology
to find answers in biology we will touch
give you an overview on that in this
specific course right in this specific
session so if you already have some
introduction so you can actually wait
for or you can uh go through some of the
additional resources that we have in
this case like bytes and molecules
introduction to bioinformatics course
and
gain some more familiarity in the area
that you already know and also in some
of the areas that you are interested in
but you have and you lack in reality and
those who are starting afresh in
bioinformatics this is a course that you
would definitely want to complete both
the session video session and also the
associated resources that you can see
from here because this will be the
stepping stone for variety of different
terminologies that we are going to
discuss and different ways and different
logic that we are going to discuss in
the upcoming sessions so you can
straight away access part of the online
resources Associated online Resources by
clicking onto this link right let's
let's do that
okay it's opening in the same page so I
want to go back because I don't want to
lose this one
so what we wanted to demonstrate you is
uh
over the course of providing you the
resources for
um for each and every session that we
have been discussing that we will be
discussing uh in the lectures and in the
videos we would have hand-picked
specific lesson from the course from the
learn portal for you to refer to okay so
in the learn portal as recovery
demonstrated you we have courses and
each and every courses are separated
into different lessons in most of these
cases
we would have referred to specific
lesson from this for Associated
resources that we are discussing in the
lecture so that you can quickly refer to
what we have been talking about and um
and uh
yeah and some of the methods that we are
discussing during this session but
throughout the course in which the
lesson is actually referred to the
course will contain more information
regarding other phases of the same uh
yeah of the same topic right let's uh
let's not take the introduction to
bioinformatics where we have a refer to
the whole lesson in itself let's go down
for example
let's take this Associated resource of
visualization of 16s metagenomics data
and introduction to metagenomics right
so if you go here this is going to be
very specific to what we will be
discussing in that particular session
right so you can for example look at
how to for visualize and analyze
metagenomics data which we will go
through today also right so this is
going to be an extremely specific lesson
and you can quickly refer to what we
have discussed and then here but
over the course of other lessons that is
present in the metagenomics course you
can get an idea about
other facets of the data analysis pardon
this
slowness of the server for some reason
it's really slow okay
okay I just wanted to show you or
demonstrate you the lesson and course by
structure where we will be referring to
another lesson as resources if you have
time and if you are interested you are
free to check and
go through the other lessons in the
subsequent and cases right that's what I
wanted to discuss here
all right
wait a second give me a minute
yeah I think it is taking time for
everybody to load as well so that's okay
so that's what I wanted to show you the
lesson and core structure will be
helpful if you are going to invest in
more time for example in learning one
specific omics data analysis and the
background behind it while you are going
through this program okay let's go ahead
so this program is actually separated
into different omics data types that we
will be dealing with and what are the
considerations for performing that
analysis what will you learn when you
perform such an analysis and for example
how to perform this analysis in the
associated Big Data server T bioinfo
server that we will be discussing in
detail today so this is a link for that
you can
you can quickly
check
this one load it up and check this one
with you okay and let me find ways to
share
okay
so let's go back to the course structure
we'll come back to the server later
so after getting yourself introduced and
after getting yourself a good overview
of different bioinformatics uh um
terminologies and applications Etc we
will start with the father of all omix
data analysis genomics right so genomics
data analysis we will discuss about for
example what are we looking for when we
are performing genomics data analysis
right and uh
um
how do we Define for example a variant
which is what we are looking for and how
do we Define a mutation right and what
are the effects of variance functional
effects of variance and what the
functional consequences of finding a
mutation and when can we annotate a
variant and how and when can we annotate
a variant into for example
um
some clinically relevance and with
clinical relevance and with
with toxicity parameters Etc
associations that we will also discuss
so this is while discussing this I will
also show you how to perform such an
analysis in the associated lessons T bio
info platform right and before even
going to the analysis we will also
discuss what are the file formats that
we are going to deal with and which is
how the data is stored into different
file formats or the data is actually
kind of
interchanged between different file
formats which is going to add up to the
complexity and also to the knowledge of
the knowledge that you can gain from the
data so let's quickly for example go
into
um
a demonstration of how a genomics data
analysis can be performed in the Big
Data server T by info server so those
who have login credentials to the server
you can log in and then follow along
with it right so in the genomics and
under the genomics analysis under
genomic section in the tyo info server
so we will find this mutation analysis
and the mutation invariant and the
parallel analysis of variant data so we
have to go through that but um
to help you understand how to set up a
pipeline of analysis
using some pre-loaded input files and
pre-loaded parameters we have prepared
lot of demo pipelines right so these
demo pipelines can be accessed using
these drop down option under each one of
these analysis pipeline options that we
have here so wherever you find this drop
down option there's a demo pipeline
inside that that you can test so today
we are going to deal with what we are
going to discuss
let's take a breast cancer mutations
tp53 demo pipeline so it is addressed as
demos Etc so you click on this
so when you click on this you will get
more or less the same screen that you
will get when you click on the analysis
pipeline link right except for the fact
that because we have pre-loaded the
input file you will not get the option
to load your input files again so but
other than that if this demo pipeline so
these demo pipelines will guide you
through the process of setting up an
analysis for genomics data analysis the
input is going to be fast queue files
for multiple different samples and
different sample conditions for which
you are interested in studying so this
particular input is to understand
um
variants in the tp53g using Target
sequencing approach so targeted
sequencing approach so we have already
set some of the input parameters and
input files here so we will start with
the python start setting up the pipeline
so in click Start then you will get a a
short overview of What that particular
step is doing to your data and and some
for example you will get to know uh
further in the next few options if you
have a method that is linked with the
citation or that is linked with the
research paper then we give you a small
gist of what that method is going to do
to your data and what are the inferences
that we are going to get and what is the
type of um
output that is going to be passed on to
the next analysis uh algorithm and if as
I mentioned if it when it is uh
published in a yeah when it has a
publication and the research paper then
we cite that also so let's you can click
on the citation and check out
um some more details about this
particular analysis so notice that after
we have pressed start I have an option
that is highlighted with which we I can
proceed to set up my pipeline right so
now after setting up the start uh option
then I have an option to trim my first
few files using turbomatic so what does
this trigma Matic do how does it trim
and uh what is the use
and and how are we going to incorporate
that in the analysis all that will be
discussed in the uh respective session
so now we are going to get an overview
how to set up this one and get yourself
familiarized with what we are what we
are dealing with look we have the
citation link so you can link and then
um get more information about the
scientific background of this particular
algorithm and then after setting up the
trimmatic and cleaning up the
pre-processing the passcode files and
the reads then we are going to set up
mapping
um procedure right so mapping is where
all of your reads are going to be mapped
to that particular
place where it can find its match to so
um
that happens using several algorithms
that we will be discussing over the
course of this introduction program but
one of the most popular algorithm uh
that is uh yeah that is widely used and
that is also
um converted into other forms uh in in
the mapping world right the mapping
algorithm uh options is about I2
algorithm or about I algorithm right so
we use bow tie we can use bow tie to map
our reads onto the rare respective
positions in the reference genome so
that is what we are going to deal with
here since um I did not tell but it is
it is not
um
I think it is understood that since this
is the data that deals with breast
cancer mutations in the tp53g the
reference genome is going to be human
okay
uh yes a suction if you have uh just uh
obtained your uh login credentials or
obtained your registration then you will
have to wait for at least 24 hours to
get your account activated in the three
bio info server so that is why I said
it's about A2
right about A2 is a very popular
algorithm it is used in several other uh
uh this also right so you can click on
this one and yeah edited you can click
on this and get the respective
publication also right okay so and after
that we can we can visualize our mapping
of the reads onto their respective
places like this we will navigate such a
visualization tool in in a while
and you can read through what you can
gain from this visualization option in
this visualization setup so we always do
that because we want a visual
confirmation of how our reads are mapped
onto their respective positions and then
the whole idea of this particular
genomic pipeline is to identify variance
right we have look at this we have
several different variant callers
usually called us right and variant
calling algorithms that we can get our
hands to when you are going to set up
your own analysis you will have options
not only to mutate to but several of
these different algorithms that if you
want to obtain or if you want to
estimate variance for your sample you
can use that in your pipeline so now for
this one we are going to use mutate too
and yeah
and more information regarding how mutex
is going to work and how it is going to
find out Etc
so it's a little bit slow today for some
reasons I also checked before it's
little bit slow let's go ahead and then
we have another option for example of
once you have identified variance right
mutex two will identify variants that
are present in your sample compared to
the reference genome it's just going to
list out all the variants that you can
find in the
um
yeah that you can find in your sample
and once you have found that once you
have this list right it's really useful
to find out or compare these two
publicly available resources that
documents the pathogenicity that
documents The annotation in in disease
related annotations of these uh
um of these variants uh so that we can
use that information to further
implicate the biological reasoning or
biological implications of the variance
that we have just identified so
that can be done using The annotation
annotation option so when you select
this option you will get
um yeah you will get a choice to choose
either clinvar or dbsnp to annotate your
variance so once you have done this
let's click end
so uh ending the pipeline will ask you
to
will take you to the output options that
you can download and visualize and
navigate around and generally understand
what are the outputs and what are what
am I going to do with these outputs
how can I improve my learning from
performing such a genomics data analysis
by going through the outputs right so
that's what we that's that's what we
give you uh when you sign up uh in this
program and uh yeah when you have your
even when you have your demo credentials
in the uh T-mobile info server you have
access full access to all the demo
pipeline which will again give you
access to how we set up these pipelines
and how we let you visualize the output
in the visualization tools and uh
dashboards and all the pipeline output
files which you can
um obtained from this list right we
don't have to download this but I have
already downloaded this but we don't
have to download this we can use the
inter interpret I mean we can use the um
interactive visualization tool to gain
access to all of these output files so
let's click on this genome visualization
option and let it load so
so if you check the output files right
we have a VCF file a list of VCR file
that we have identified from from mutec
to and we even before that we have
mapping stats table and which is going
to give you statistics of how the
mapping of our first queue reads reads
in the first view format to their
respective positions in the genome
reference genome so this will give you
an example of how many different samples
do we have and what are the files that
are used for analysis and what can we
learn from this during the visualization
option it's going to open up like this
so in this window right or in this
option you will get the mapping
statistics table pre-loaded right and
some of the important parameters that
you would want to confirm and you would
want to compare and understand the
quality of your difference of different
samples that you have given for the
analysis is to check the overall
alignment rate right and how many were
paired right you see when these are
really high in the orders of 90s then
you have a good data a good meaning all
of the parent end or all of the weeds
that you find are have their partner in
the Paradigm sequencing uh um option or
the pattern sequencing uh
output and out of those or out of these
different parameters we find 99 more
than 99 of them have found their
respective positions and have very high
alignment rate to the genes or to the
position and the reference genome so
this is what we want to check this gives
you also
um
more information about for example the
quality of the samples right here so we
can find out if suddenly one of your
sample has a drop in the alignment rate
then we want we would want to
um check what's wrong with the sample
and how do we deal with the sample
that's that's a major question do we
still
use that sample integrate the sample to
our analysis or do we discard that that
depends upon how many samples do you
have and what is wrong with the samples
also that you can also think so if you
have a big screen that will be very
useful but for for Simplicity I'm going
to I have completed going through the
mapping statistics and I'm very happy
with the mapping statistics of my input
file quality of the input file so I'm
closing this uh data or closing this
particular
option okay then what do we have here we
have several of the tracks or each one
of this is a file
and we can
we can check these boxes to display them
here the order in which we want to
display them will help uh navigating
this uh visualization tool also okay
okay so for example I would like to have
my reference genome right on top and uh
I mean this is just a preference for
some others they will have want to have
their reference genome at the bottom so
I would want to have my reference genome
right on top so it's going to load up
the referencium and you can zoom into
the reference you know we will do that
later and then we would want to load up
The
annotation file for the reference genome
which is also uh which which will also
which will help you for example to
navigate through the genome
uh in the uh yeah in the range of genes
right or else we have to navigate
through the genome with the uh with the
loci and with the positions genome
positions Etc that's going to be a
little bit confusing so now we have
loaded both of these things and there is
yeah
there's not much information here but we
will do that and let's load couple of
samples or let's load the VCF output
here right so VCF is also loaded so why
is nothing display that's one of the
major question that we would want to ask
right if if this is uh if this is the
analysis output why is nothing displayed
so this is where just blind performance
or blind analysis will not help you here
right remember what I mentioned about
setting up this particular data analysis
or genomics data analysis we have set up
data analysis for targeted genome
sequencing data so that targeted
sequencing data targets only the tp53g
but we are we are in some other position
where
um nothing is being recorded and nothing
is being analyzed so let's go to tp53g
when you have your gtf file or
annotation file loaded and then this is
a use uh usefulness of the GTA file you
can just type the gene name and we can
navigate to that specific position
so once you go there then you can see
that okay my VCR file is starting to get
get populated and I have their exons and
their and the introns mapped by the GTA
file that I have obtained from the
reference ncbi reference table etc etc
so for Simplicity I'm going to open this
up and I'll show what happens right
let's zoom in to this one particular
section right
we have to go here yeah and and
can select this and zoom to this region
and now you can start to see the
sequence if you zoom in even further
some more
yes now you can start to see the
sequence and this has lots of
information but we would we don't want
to have uh reading frames or trans amino
acid translation different reading
frames now so I'm going to turn the top
right show translation I'll turn that
off I want the forward and reverse so
let's have it and let's rearrange this
one little bit and okay
um
okay so what do we have here I don't
have any variant in this particular
region so I'm navigating through the
variant file to find a variant let's
zoom out a little bit
okay in this particular Exon I don't
have any variant at all that's
surprising that itself is a good uh
information
okay we have one here so let's click on
this variant and see what this actually
tells us so this tells us some other
characteristics of the variant and for
example what are the samples in my
sample list contains this variant and in
what capacity
Etc so these are the information that
you will get while navigating this this
is much navigating a mapped this is a
vampile and Sample visualizing this map
vampire and Sample this is a very
extremely qualitative job right this can
so this is done to for example
understand
these options right when you want to uh
uh for example with with your eye when
you want to navigate through the Gene
and see where we have higher uh
alignment and where we have alignment
that is a not of great quality then you
can do this and if you remember earlier
we have not for example uh let's not
click on this feature details let's see
how
it's
close this feature details
okay let's start uh
enabling some uh some for example some
samples upon two samples and see what
that actually gives us
yeah
so when you do that this is going to
give us alignments and it's going to
help you visualize alignments in these
specific regions
and now you can see that how the reads
are aligned to this specific area and
let it load this alignment and let's
zoom out a little bit more
okay so you get more information here
and the alignment this this is going to
give you a plot or bar graph of the
quality of the alignment that you will
see so you will discuss this in in
Greater detail when we are going through
that specific sessions I just want to
show you that you can qualitatively view
this uh output and and make sense of
even
make sense of your uh this thing yeah
okay we got the uh Hill plot also they
are going to show you the coverage and
that's going to show you how much uh the
alignment
yeah for example we have more coverage
in this area where we have Peaks and
less coverage in the area where we have
traps so we will discuss little bit in
Greater detail and once you have also
gotten your respective credentials we
would also use that in the session to do
that also okay let's quickly move on
so that's about it and you can also
you're also free to download this VCF
file right I've already done that and
then open this in any uh text editor so
that you can generally understand the
structure of ECF file how it is reported
and what are the other information which
will be very useful if you want to
perform on some Downstream analysis in
in R and any other tool right okay with
that let's move on from genomics data
analysis and if you have any questions
this is regarding genomics data analysis
this is the time that you would want to
ask me and reserve your very specific
and very detailed questions to the
sessions and here we are just having an
overview and I already gone over the
time let's quickly go to T bioinfo
platform so let's go back
to the program page where once we have
completed learning about genomics data
analysis then we are going to amp up the
level of understanding to consider
metagenomics data analysis where we will
be focusing on quantifying the microbial
population using the metagenomics data
so how it is done and what are the
considerations all of this will be
for example uh discussed in two or three
sessions that two sessions that we are
focusing on metagenomics data analysis
so well to find respective demo pipeline
for metagenovation excuse me data
analysis you come all the way down in
the metagenomic section we have two
analysis set up one for kind two
analysis the other one for data to
analysis so the difference between these
will also be discussed in the program so
it will be little bit out of scope for
what we are dealing with okay
so let's take time to results and
um okay Malik we are using this Big Data
server Big Data uh bioinformatics server
that you will also use to perform this
analysis to set up pipelines of analysis
in genomics metagenomics and
transcriptomics data right uh
when you get your access to this
particular server after signing up in
the learn portal so after signing up in
the loan portal you will get the access
um after approximately or roughly 24
hours and you can
navigate the portal and access all the
demo pipeline that I'm actually showing
you and when you are going to set up
your own Pipeline and this is the
reference that you will use to set up
your own python let's quickly go through
and for example take um
um uh and let's take that let's take
amplicon sequencing 16 is 18 as data to
analysis and take um
analysis for samples with samples uh
um under ciao dietary regime and the
samples under high fat dietary regime so
we start again now you would have gotten
or understood that uh how the
organization of these algorithms and uh
into into pipelines that that we can use
as click and select opt
click and select uh selectable
Tools in this server is it's been
used so
usually the analysis is actually
separated and segregated into multiple
sections there is a color code to this
section the pre-processing and mapping
and other colors will follow generic
color code that is consistent in the
whole bioinformatics a big data
bioinformatics server uh T bio info
server right
yes uh questions we will actually help
you build your own pipeline right if it
is for your data then we will help you
build your own Pipeline and for the
purpose of learning the different
sections of the pipeline and what does
it focus and what are the choices that
one can make in setting up this analysis
right so for those things you know we
will refer to the demo Pipeline and yeah
and Etc and also there are multiple
other pipelines specific pipelines that
are referred in the lesson uh while you
are going through so when you have your
own data then you can sign up to the
research fellowship program where you
can perform analysis in with your own
data and set up pipelines and
communicate with me every week about
what you have what you have learned from
your data and what is the focus of your
research Etc so yeah for more
information please get in touch with us
using supported point or Point okay
let's quickly go through uh the output
so what when you set up such an analysis
like metagenomics data analysis what
will you get so that's a Focus right how
to navigate through this analysis
different analysis option will be
discussed in the respective sections
let's speed up a little bit so you have
multiple visualization two so let's for
example take one of these visualization
tool like relative abundance of that
attacks are and then external dashboard
which is also uh which is an interactive
dashboard yes so let it load for a while
yes so this is a typical abundance
proportionate abundance plot that you
would have definitely noticed whenever
you are going through a metagenomics
paper or metagenomics research paper
right
yeah I will I will take these questions
after after this section so in this one
you can navigate or you can understand
the
um
proportionate abundance of specific
bacteria and you can for example
interactively find out what the
bacterial genus is this is like
bacteroidities right yes bacteria
deities phyla and that is going to be
abundant in some of the some of my
sample and not abundant in other samples
so I have to go to this sample and there
understand their sample condition to
find their relevance so that information
can also be found from the dashboard we
have the same plot in a different facet
here and separated by the condition of a
dietary condition that these samples are
undergone so I can find that for example
one specific uh
um
phyla it's like uh this is
perfect Mona right which is
abundant only in or which is present
only in the samples that take high fiber
diet and is completely absent in the
sample that takes chowder these are all
the interesting uh implications that you
can find and relations that we can find
that we can try to relate that with the
diet so you can also for example
um perform uh abundance analysis as a
group where you have you could for
example select different conditions and
find out how their distribution is and
what their mean abundance level is and
what can we understand from this we can
generally find that the abundance is
um the median abundance is lower for the
samples that take high fiber diet
compared to high fat diet sorry high fat
diet compared to normal diet
okay
yes we can perform Alpha and beta
diversity analysis and
okay it's getting really specific we
will discuss you know in a short while
okay let's go up again uh we can
actually navigate through for example
um diversity uh visualization using an
MDS or pcoa depending upon the choice
that you have opted for while performing
this analysis and you can if you drop
down you will find options to select uh
annotation at a different level if your
data has annotations at more than one
level like Diet at different week then
we can use those different options to
color and to shape this to find relevant
patterns so that's what we will that's
what we will discuss in the metagenomics
data analysis and also when to use what
algorithm like when to use chyme or when
to use
um data 2 Etc so this dashboard will
also give you
a tabular output which you can
interactively find and interactively
download so that um if you want to
perform a downstream analysis using some
other using r or other python code that
we have also referred to in the
respective sections and respective
courses you can use these input to
perform those analysis and we have all
of this information in the respective
courses and will also be discussed in
detail during this section during the
session videos okay let's take some of
the questions before quickly going
through
um
setting up of transcriptomics data
analysis what transcriptomics data or
rnac data can help us understand in
terms of omics data analysis let's take
some of the questions
um
we say okay what is quality control
filtering during the process vasuda I
mentioned that it's it's about filtering
your reads based on the qualities code
that is associated with each and every
base call during the process of
sequencing itself the sequencer machine
will associate each and every position
with their respective quality score and
to maximize the potential or to maximize
interpretation and to maximize the
statistical relevance of your data we
can actually restrict the reads or
restrict the
input file to specific Quality quality
score so that lower Quality Base calls
which is more often related with or
which is more often ambiguous and maybe
noise or maybe due to Signal overlap
will not be considered and will not
actually
disturb our initial symbol so our will
not
for example lower the statistical
relevance that we want to find out okay
let's see what's the next question that
we have what's the difference between
genomics and metagenomics data analysis
in short genomics data analysis is for
sample from one organism usually the
organism that you are trying to study it
can be a pathogen like SARS crypto virus
it can be human like the one that we
performed in the cancer comparison
analysis metagenomic data analysis is a
is for a whole community of bacteria or
microbes more specifically that is
present in the different that is present
where you are sampling from if you are
sampling fecal samples then it then you
are trying to understand metagenomics of
microbial Community present in your gut
you can sample from oral a cavity then
you are going to sample metagenomics of
your saliva and etc etc you get the
drift right there we are not focusing on
the host which is going to be us but we
are focusing on the microbes that are
living inside and on us that is
beneficial and very few of them will be
detrimental and the idea is to find out
the balance and relate that balance with
the different disease condition ah
defines metagenomics data analysis
etcetera that's what that's where it
differs from genomics data analysis and
can we do alpha and beta diversity
analysis yes we can do and one of the
way in which we can understand this
difference in abundance level of
microbes to specific phenotypical
condition or to specific Disease
Association or to conditional
Association is to study Alpha and beta
diversity using different parameters
okay okay and what is the bacterial
resolution to know the significance
between experimental groups okay
we are going to stick our analysis to
what has been uh to the resolution of
the silver and very well known databases
so the resolution is how far can you
resolve in your bacteria in your
abundance on proportional table right if
I have information and if I have
annotation all the way to species strain
level then I have higher resolution but
for some of the bacteria the genus
species strain information is not
classified and they will they will fall
under lower resolution data with
uncharacterized genus species and Etc
other ranks yes you will get the
recording and thank you I think we are
done with the questions let's move on so
in the next set of
sessions we are going to introduce you
to the wonderful world of
transcriptomics data analysis and to
give you the pers to give you a
perspective rnsic data or
transcriptomics data is a mo is a is the
most frequently used omics data type
analysis till date and I think very soon
metagenomics will overtake that but at
least now transcriptomics usage is
actually pretty well maintained so we
are first going to show you how to
perform these uh again
um and use the pipeline to quantify the
gene expression which is the whole idea
of transcriptomics data analysis to find
out
um at what expression quantity each and
every Gene in my sample is extra stat
right some of the gene might be
expressed at a higher quantity and some
of them may be expressed at a very
Baseline quantity right what is it
quantification and what can we learn
from this quantification done on
different sample conditions my sample
conditions can simply be
um for example transcriptomics data
studied for people under diabetic and
the people that are healthy or it can
also be people like cancer patients who
are treated with specific drug and
cancer patients who are not treated with
particular drugs so those those kind of
associations and those kind of
differences and implications that you
can make using transcriptome Etc but it
doesn't stop there right let's let's
take a look at what how to set up this
uh wonderful pipeline right under
transcriptomics Section you come to bulk
RNA seek and then you have several demo
pipelines let's take one of them
cell lines
and now you get the drift right genomics
and transcriptomics share many of the
algorithms because uh basically they are
the same transcriptomics is a subset of
your genomics genome right only the
expressed part so we again use the same
pre-processing technique like Sim
the reads for adapter sequences and for
unclean sequences or clean sequences
with lower quality score as somebody
asked me and then we again use PCR clean
to drop out some of the PCR duplicates
and we go all the way to mapping onto
transcripts right now I am completely
skipping all these but you will get lot
of information on what is mapping onto
the zero and what is mapping onto the
junction what is Exon detection what is
isoform construction and what moving on
what is mapping on to the transcripts
how they are different when to choose
what algorithm during the course right
we will get that information
and this is also available in the
transcriptomics course right which is
one of the most bulkier cores that we
have in the learn portal so you are free
to check that out also
so once we have mapped the reads onto
their respective places in the genome
that like what we do instead of looking
for differences as we have done in the
genomics data analysis now we are going
to look for quantification of genes
based on number of reads that are mapped
onto those specific genes that is done
using this expression level
quantification algorithm which are
plenty you want to help you
okay it's meta transcriptomics right I
think it is meta transcriptomics it's
not transcriptomics metagenomics it's
actually meta transcriptomics which is
also very unique and yeah we are not
going to deal a lot with meta
transcriptomics
um if I have time I'll tell you why
okay let's
end the pipeline and then you will get
for example a wonderfully interactive
dashboard which I encourage all of you
to check uh this out okay
so when when we stop at this level
expression level right instead of
completely skipping the downstream
analysis like differential gene
expression and Analysis right and uh we
get until until this interactive uh
report right somebody asked me about the
quality of the reads and this is one way
to assess the quality of the reads to
check the multi-qc report that is going
to be outputted or that's going to be
coming out of your analysis there are
several sections of this multi-qc report
but I am going to show you uh this is a
mapping of the leads course quality
scores for each and every position in
your reads you see how good this is in
the green green section or better area
right these 27 or 30 will form the
filter based on which you can filter out
some of the positions that are going to
be ambiguous in our Downstream analysis
that's what is going to that is what
filtering out based on Qs or quality
control of fastq file would
so this is one way and then again you
can for example
navigate the gene expression
right this is going to take long time to
load so while it is loading let's go
back again here I want to show you
I want to quickly show you
um while performing this transcriptomics
data analysis your Downstream analysis
can form part of this uh transcriptomics
pipeline so in that case we can we will
also include
these differential gene expression
analysis where you can statistically
identify genes that are Express at a
different rate in one type of sample
condition compared to the other side
type of sample condition other sample
condition so that is the whole aim of
using the quantification or quantity
quantifying your gene expression uh is
to compare at what level at what
quantity the genes are expressed between
my two different sample conditions or
multiple different sample conditions
usually it is two uh y uh because if
it's more than two uh there are
different ways to set up the analysis
but again that we will discuss during
the session or it will take long time
okay when you perform such a such a
pipeline or a such a pipeline yes you
will get these kind of results where you
will
you can open up the dashboard now we
have volcano plot and also dashboard
right we will let's see if this is
loaded or not this this will take long
time to load this is just a gene
expression visualization of gene
expression for different samples okay
let's take the external dashboard
okay
so here you will get
heat map of top 20 genes that are
expressed for your sample conditions
right we will we will know that which
sample belongs to what condition and
then based on which we can understand
okay my top 20 genes can easily
um segregate between or separate between
the sample conditions here okay this
data is not that great because we find
that not many of the genes are
identified as statistically significant
from here right so we can find out what
is this G this is a egfr okay growth
factor understood because I think this
is a cancel data cell lines data and
this is another Gene so d p y s you can
come down so since we have found out
only two of these genes to be
statistically significant run they are
down regulated upregulated we can
mention those genes here e g f r
R and then and what is the other Gene
dpy SL2 right
d p y yeah okay when you do this then
you can understand look at this both of
them have a almost similar expression
level and they are extremely
um Express at a lower quantity for these
sample and Express at a higher quantity
for the other sample right
that is what we can identify from this
one usually when you perform this
analysis
um using um a different data set you
will have plenty of genes that are
identified to be statistically
significant and upregulated and down
regulated so we will get examples of
that during the course and etcetera so
this comparative analysis of gene
expression is just one part of
Downstream analysis that you can perform
on transcriptomics data and then we are
going to focus on for example how to
extend
um your data or how to apply Advanced
statistical analysis like uh data mining
approaches like machine learning tools
to your structured data data that you
can get from metagenomics that you can
get from genomics data that you can get
from transcriptomics data is what is
going to be covered in the last few
sessions and we are going to introduce
you to the concept under the application
of single cell transcriptomics which is
a world by itself and we will also
discuss what is the one that is
different between single cell and bulk
cell and how is that going to improve
our knowledge in understanding the
biology of the samples that you are
trying to study and finally
we will conclude on how to find where to
find these publicly available data and
how to take some of these publicly
available data and formulate a valid
hypothesis and permanent a valid
question for which you can design
methodologies and then address those
methodology in a research type
internship
yeah the search internship uh program
which we will discuss uh a lot in this
session and also you can also get uh
information about the research
fellowship program uh yeah from our um
from our learn portal also right so I
already took a lot of time and from
borrowed a lot of time from ojaswi and
um
let me pass the stage to oh just be now
and if you have any questions please uh
put that up in the chat so when we have
time we will discuss them uh
um after ogsv's session or I will keep
answering or I will keep responding
to your queries in the chat thank you
very much for the interactive session
and let me pass the stage to ogc I think
right uh yes sir so for now to
um share details about the program
registration and the scholarship form
I'd like to pass on the stage to shubham
so the stage is all here
thank you sugary
so hello everyone I am shubham Kumar I
am the business development and the
marketing associate here at Pine biotech
so let me first share my screen first
yeah sugary could you confirm is my
screen is visible
oh we can see your Zoom can you share
the program page
yeah
is it visible now
not yet it's showing Zoom
just a second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah now is it visible foreign
can you go to the program page and let
me see if I can see that are you sharing
the program
yeah I'm sharing the program page
okay I'm not able to see that yet
foreign
[Music]
page for introduction to bioinformatics
multiomics so uh I'll show you the link
first so you can go through this link
after the
session and yes
so yes as you can see on my screen the
this is the program page for
introduction to bioinformatics
multiomics here you will get to learn
about genomics metagenomics
transcriptomics and the Machine learning
also so this it will commence from 23rd
Jan till 30th April so
only 10 days are left so I would request
you to hurry up and enroll yourself so
after scrolling down a bit you will see
the program overview
where we have summarized whatever you
will be learning with this program along
with the outcomes like uh you will be
able to you and know the analysis of NGS
data which will be helpful in
identifying the pathogenic germline and
somatic DNA variants you will also be
able to measure the gene expression and
detect the methylation patterns as just
not Dr raghavendran sir has told using
the T by info server so basically this
program is designed for everyone uh
including the students who don't have a
background in bioinformatics and the
biologist so that they can learn about
the Angus data analysis program
processing
so while scrolling
run more you will see an interactive
calendar with some of the dates are
highlighted like you can see 23rd gen is
highlighted so on that particular day we
will be conducting the live sessions and
on the right hand side of that calendar
you will see the topics to be covered in
that particular session
like in the first session we will cover
the introduction with the faculty and
the program introduction then we will
have the demonstration of the slack
Channel and various program Pages then
omix logic learn courses then T bio
platform also
and on the next session which will be on
26 you will be learning about the
genomic variance and mutants mutations
so here you can see all the dates of
your session and the topics which we'll
be covering next comment on a bit more
you will see that we have three
different tenures 45 days 60 days and 90
days so uh first I'll tell you about the
common resources which are present in
all these 10
yes the common resources are online
tutorials you will we have the access
then project examples also then Hands-On
coding session then session recordings
by chance if you miss any of the session
then we will provide you with the
session recordings you will also get the
online vendor support and the technical
support and after the completion of
these standards you will get the
certificate of completion for 60 days uh
what extra you will be getting is One on
One Mentor session and a chance to
propose your research work and if if and
yeah if you can complete a research
project then you can even present in as
a poster on various International
symposiums also and in the 90 days apart
from these outcomes you will get the one
on one benefit session and then ample
amount of time to work on your research
project work and get it published in a
peer review journal so these are the
difference between the 45 days 60 days
and 90 days standard coming to the
pricing part so as you can see the
prices are here in INR so for 45 days it
is 7500 for six
days it is 9 triple nine and for 90 days
it is 14 triple nine now if someone is
from uh another country like from USA or
any other country so you can simply
select your uh currency by clicking on
the drop down menu here like just say uh
in USD so in USD you can see the amounts
like 150 300 and 450 dollars and for
also uh for African participants the
prices are a naira also so now if anyone
wants to uh like enroll for this program
so what basically you have to do is
let's say uh I'm interested in the 90
day standard so I'll simply click on buy
now button
and here you
see your checkout page so
it was project on all the 10 years so
the coupon code for 50 scholarship is
multi 50. everything is in caps 50 yeah
so after the coupon code click on
like
and
yeah you can see the coupon is applied
successfully so just fill up your basic
user details and click on this checkbox
and after that select this type method
PayPal method also if you want to pay by
an alternative mode then we also have
alternative to proceed with the payment
part so if you have any query regarding
the restoration part please let us know
by the time I'll share you the steps to
empathy keep encoding this
thank you so much
so meanwhile shubham shares these steps
for registering if anyone has any
queries let me know
Malik is asking what about group
registration
yeah we also have the group registration
also so um Malik could you please uh
send me your email ID we will revert
back to you with the process for group
registration part
yes Malik has already shared his email
ID so we'll be getting back to you okay
yeah
so does anyone have any further queries
regarding registration or scholarship
let us know in the chat and we'll be
happy to help
can you please share the registration
link one more time
I think okay you have said thank you I
just found it yes
for any queries I'm sharing the email ID
and the contact number of our Marketing
Manager
so at any point of time if you're having
any queries you can reach out to us
through this email ID or contact number
and the number is also active on
WhatsApp
[Music]
so we'll pause for a couple of seconds
for the participants to
share their query if not we'll be ending
today's webinar
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yes or no we will share the recordings
under each and every
um
session details right one thing that I
forgot to mention is uh under the
resources section of uh let me share it
quickly I think do we have it or have it
closed it I think it seems like a
has anybody gotten your uh program page
yes yeah
foreign
so for example here under these
Associated resources like uh no no not
there go to the pro go to go up school
up to the go to the first session please
foreign
yes okay so here you see that there are
the list of associated online resources
so every time when when a session is
completed uh give it 24 hours then you
will get the session recording appearing
below that Associated online resources
you can go over the session recording at
your own Leisure if you have missed the
online session live session okay
and some of the sessions are planned to
be asynchronous meaning you will get a
link for the videos through email or
that link will also be updated on that
specific date of
uh the session has been planned to under
these online Associated online resources
if you register to this program you will
get an option to click and select
complete each and every session so that
we also can keep a tap on how far are
you uh progressing with the program and
Etc so once you register for the program
you will find these two options under
these uh under each and every one of the
session
thank you
thank you sir
all right
and if anyone has any further queries
let us know I'd be happy to help
all right is the participants have no
further queries ending today's webinar
so thank you everyone for joining
today's webinar and we look forward to
seeing you at Program start
all right thank you and have a great day